well let's take a closer look at the
palestinian resistance movement in the
occupied territories a laksa brigades is
an armed group that emerged during the
second intifada it splintered from
fatter and at times operates alongside
islamic jihad
there are numerous palestinian groups
that are resisting israel's illegal
occupation a palestinian liberation
organization known as a plo was formed
in the 60s and operates as an umbrella
group of several political factions and
armed groups
it excludes groups such as hamas and
islamic jihad in gaza who have opposed
all forms of negotiations with israel
hamas islamic jihad the al-aqsa martyrs
brigades among others cooperate
militarily and agree that armed
resistance to the occupation is the only
way to end it and to achieve palestinian
self-determination
barghouti the senior palestine
correspondent from underweight's news
website she joins us live from ramallah
thanks for joining us here now to what
extent is there genuine support for the
al-aqsa martyrs brigades
i think we have a little technical
problem there you may have muted your
microphone i'm not sure if you can try
and unmute that to see if we can still
speak to you do you want to try that
again if you can uh
hear me now i'll ask that that question
again then to to what extent is there
genuine support for the al-aqsa martyrs
brigades do you think
i think you're framing the question
wrong the support isn't for al-aqsa
martyrs brigade in specific prior to
that you had the palestinian islamic
jihad and an armed coalition come out of
janine during the onslaught by the
israeli military and
as armed you know palestinian resistance
ibrahimovic was born in 2003. his
birthday was october 13th that means
he's not yet even 19. this line of
nablus that we're hailing and and we're
iconizing we need to recognize that
places
where armed resistance is growing um is
happening in areas like jeanine like
nablus like
that have been under an incredibly
brutal suffocation um that is systemic
by the israeli authorities and enforced
by the israeli army the vanguard of
israel's colonial project
but given what you say how do the
divisions within
the armed movement and the wider
palestinian leadership hamper efforts
for palestinians to progress
i i think that's a question that was
more relevant a couple of years ago
right now after the unity intifada of
last year you saw a reclamation
of palestinian identity in the
collective and that includes palestinian
in exile and diaspora the division of
palestinians was not simply um within
the political factions it's geopolitical
and it's enforced by israel you have
palestinians with west bank id
id jerusalem and those with israeli
citizenship and i think that was
fragmented last year and if you notice a
lot of
what what is reiterated especially by
palestinian armed resistance groups is
that we are here for the palestinian
collective these are generations that
are quite literally um
probably in their early 20s um to you
know 30s and all they knew is an israeli
brutal occupation and that's kind of
what's happening here it's it is de
facto protection the israeli army raided
nablus at the dawn hours
and besieged ibrahimovic whose final
words were
do not let go of the gun
i think i'm going to be killed i'm under
siege pray for me and now imagine being
19 years old having to defend yourself
and a nuclear power
army raids your town consistently to
target you imagine the fear he felt and
still he withstood and tried to protect
so i think the support is seen from that
lens that we continuously keep getting
killed and this new generation
is finding that this is not the life to
live
despite what you say is there enough of
a cohesive approach
even after so many years of conflict
siege and blockade
hope for what
and which conflict are you referring to
you mean our ethnic cleansing
as we're looking at the situation now is
there enough of a cohesive approach for
palestinians
i think that's also dependent on i've
said this before it's not just on the
palestinians we the palestinians as a
people we are cleaning up the mess of
decision makers in terms of policy in
terms of enforcement in terms of
continuously funding israel and i
apologize but in framing of journalists
to keep calling it a conflict it's not
this is a military aggression this is an
assault
and israel is violating every u.n
convention there ever was on protection
of human life
very embarkative we very much appreciate
your time thank you for joining us here
on al jazeera
thank you